so we're at the Bandai Namco booth at e3
2014 checking out grid Autosport grid
Autosport is one of those games that
were really trying to come through with
the passion of racing we've got a number
of different racing disciplines
represented currently you're checking
out the Touring Car discipline where
you're literally taking these what would
be purchasable cars for everyday driving
and they race some at they race them out
for touring car racing in the European
tracks the game is coming to PlayStation
3 Xbox 360 and PC come June 24th as you
can see the action is definitely tight
you will be rubbing and racing at the
same time outside of touring part you do
get to do some drifting there's some
Street car racing
there's also open wheel racing in grid
Autosport the guys at code masters have
done a great job of really capturing the
passion and the ambiance of the
different disciplines that's contained
in the game and as you guys know brick
code message that obviously a story
developer that's worked on a ton of
different racing games so when it comes
to auto sport they know what they are
doing right now we're gonna try to have
Nick here that's doing the driving catch
up and pass some of these guys no
pressure Nick so if you're a fan of grid
Autosport obviously you've played the
previous two games with with this newest
iteration we definitely want to make
sure that people know that the details
the physics have all been optimized for
the PlayStation 3 and Xbox 360 and
obviously for PC fans as well the
physics in the game the damage models
are very accurate when you're crashing
into other cars your car will take
damage and also the performance will be
affected such as if you're knocking off
bumpers hoods your aerodynamics will be
affected car will slow down if you're
taking hits to the side and your
suspension gets damaged your car will
drift drift to the lip left or right as
you're driving that also affects your
outright speed at the end of the day so
even though you can rub and take on
damage it's not recommended because that
will affect your performance there are a
ton of tracks that players will get to
enjoy throughout the world and it's
definitely one of those games that gives
you a wide breadth of experience when it
comes to experiencing Auto Sport on a
global scale and then of course for our
friends in Brazil in Latin America there
is Brazilian stock car racing included
in the game as well so for our latin
america fans we want to make sure that
they know that so thanks for checking
out grid Autosport that's coming out on
PlayStation 3 Xbox 360 and PC on June
24th in North America and it's also
going to be available in Latin America
so look out toward the game then we'll
see you on the track